all right guys bang bang absolute
breaking news i just came in the studio
specifically to talk about this sec
chairman gary ginsler was just asked
whether the sec was planning to ban
bitcoin or crypto currencies the answer
no they are not considering a ban
against bitcoin or cryptocurrencies now
you may remember last week the federal
reserve chairman jerome powell was asked
the same exact question he specifically
stated no the federal reserve was not
considering any sort of ban of bitcoin
or cryptocurrencies they don't really
have that ability now today the sec
chairman asked the same exact question
banning bitcoin or crypto no they also
don't really have that level of control
or the right to do something like that
he specifically said it's up to congress
now we know multiple congress people
actually hold bitcoin or cryptocurrency
so it's unlikely that we would see a ban
coming from congress either now we kind
of zoom out and we think about why is
this so important if you remember china
an authoritarian centrally planned
economy
has already been incredibly abrasive
they have attacked this industry they
have kicked out all of the miners they
have made the trading of bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies illegal and they've
generally created an environment where
they've made it clear that if you are
into this industry if you participate in
this industry you are not welcome to do
it within their borders that's great we
should be thanking china for doing that
that opens up the door for america to
make a run at becoming the global leader
of this industry we know that many of
the miners that are kicked out of china
ended up moving their assets and setting
up in texas we believe that texas will
continue to expand and grow their market
share of the bitcoin network and that
hash rate but now the united states
faces a very unique opportunity
should we go ahead and be abrasive or
should we actually embrace this
technology i think we should do the
latter and so to see the federal reserve
chairman say we will not ban it to see
the sec chairman say we will not ban it
both good signs but now we need to go a
step further it can't simply just be
about not banning it it can't be about
simply sitting this one out from a
regular for a regulation or a banning
perspective we must embrace it we must
lean into it we should create an
environment that is conducive we should
encourage every single entrepreneur
innovator and investor anywhere in the
world if you want to build a bitcoin or
crypto business come to the united
states we will be the leader in this
technology we will incentivize you to
come here we will give you a sandbox to
play in that will not be onerous from a
regulatory standpoint we will give you
advantageous tax environment to come and
to build this we have seen that the
liquid part of the market not including
any of the privately traded companies
the liquid part of the market is now
over two trillion dollars of economic
value that has been created that is more
economic value than every single
technology unicorn that's been created
since 2000 every single unicorn added up
is not more than what has been created
in a liquid market so to see the federal
reserve chairman the sec chairman et
cetera to say we will not ban this
technology as a great sign we now must
create a positive conducive environment
if you want to build in this industry
come to the united states create jobs
here create economic impact and help us
harness the decentralized open networks
to ensure that the united states remains
the leader on a global stage if anyone
is going to benefit from these
technologies we must make sure that it's
the united states these are american
technologies they embody everything that
we have from an ethos and a value
standpoint they provide censorship
resistance they provide the ability for
individual liberty self-sovereignty and
ultimately freedom the united states
should become the leader in this
technology it's great to see the federal
reserve chairman say no we will not ban
this technology and also now the sec
chairman gary ginsler let's see what
happens moving forward but great signs
today hope you enjoyed this video if you
did make sure you like the video make
sure you subscribe to the channel and
i'll see you guys tomorrow